but you know what that doesn't mean that
hillary would have been a good choice
yeah
she was a terrible choice she's a
corrupt politician one of the most
unlikable people that's ever run for
office
she in so many ways crazy they were
trying to get it
they were trying to get people to be
supporting her just because she's a
woman
there was a lot of that it's like this
is going to be our history you know
women ladies
i stand with her so there's all these
women of this blind allegiance towards
this career politician
it's completely full of [ __ ] she's been
full of [ __ ] forever
if you watch the conversation between
james comey when james comey testified
about what he did and what they found
with the hillary clinton emails
and then her version of it she's just a
straight liar
yeah she she deleted 33 thousand how the
[ __ ] do you do that and then
and then uh even worse than that when
they rigged the dnc
they rigged the primaries so that bernie
sanders was gonna lose they mean they
she had her people into the dnc he was
crazy in advance that donna brazile book
about it is mind-blowing yes
the thing was he he was packing [ __ ]
stadiums yeah she couldn't even fill a
[ __ ] high school gymnasium
right he was pulling all the strings and
she had all the favors that she was
pulling in
and she had a [ __ ] ton of money behind
her and they were
completely arrogant and all the liberal
elite in the media thought there was no
chance that she was going to lose
she's 95 percent shoo-in to win the
presidency and
she walked around like she was like she
already thought she won
yeah but you had the benghazi [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] was up with that
exactly what the [ __ ] was going on over
there
and you know uh with the dirt that's on
i hope you know whatever
bill clinton i know you eat vegan
sometimes so he doesn't say
nobody yet yeah he had a real problem
with it well you know what when
when when uh there's the thing we ain't
rotting them out for yeah
all those times he pulled like
no but like how the [ __ ] did she get
away with that like what
like how about shaming all the women
that came out and accused him
she would attack those women and go
after them and you know i mean bourdain
talked about that recently before he
killed himself
there was a the thing about what
she had done to attack the women who
were victims of bill
you know especially earlier in your
career oh god she [ __ ]
she represented child molesters so
that's one of the things that she did
earlier in her career
she got them off you know there's a
there's a videotape that uh dave smith
was she was laughing in one of them
about the victims like i'm like what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you
she was laughing about the effectiveness
of lie detector test she's like
obviously they don't work huh
yeah yeah she's uh she's
a piece of work she is man she's a long
time
lifelong politician and a lawyer and
what about all the [ __ ] that went down
in arkansas the [ __ ] that the whole they
were all accused of
back in the day what was that the uh the
white water thing white water [ __ ]
yeah
the white water [ __ ] like and just the
string of people that have been [ __ ]
whacked too
about vince foster there's a great book
i read a long time ago called the
strange death of vince foster it's like
wait a minute what
they found the gun in his hand which you
never do when you kill yourself
when you shoot yourself when you shoot
yourself you pull that trigger blam
everything goes yeah the gun goes flying
you don't hold on to it there's recoil
in the gun
it's like you know and you blew your
brains out you're not holding your gun
anymore it goes flying
and he was he had the gun in his hand
and the blood that was missing from his
body was not on the scene of the crime
so the researchers think that they moved
his body
he was dead they put him there and
rigged the crime scene and then put a
gun in his hand up case closed
but what was he testifying he was going
and [ __ ] he knew
he had information about whitewater yeah
you know i mean what he was going to say
and
who knows they killed him you never find
out how about the guy that uh
was one of the the whistleblowers for
enron shot himself in the head twice
had he do that that shit's hilarious you
shoot yourself in the head twice
case closed that's clearly a suicide i
mean i guess
you could kind of graze your head if you
[ __ ] it out like ah
and you're like [ __ ] i'm bleeding yeah
yeah you could do it it is possible
but it's more likely somebody killed
them yeah it's just there's
people kill people it's part of the
thing when you're involved with
billion dollar deals with giant
corporations and they also tied into the
military-industrial complex
who by the way kill innocents all the
time and write it off like all this
the [ __ ] that happened with drones
what's the number it's like in the high
80s or 90 percent
innocent people killed by drones they
don't worry about that you think they're
going to worry about some guy who's
going to sink
monsanto or sink or sink the clintons
or sink anybody [ __ ] that send the boys
get whacked yeah clean it up absolutely
good shot himself the head twice
okay press conference we're all good
everything's wonderful
here's monsanto with some new glyphosate
yeah he's gonna
fix your corn